valve surprised the gaming community
this week with the announcement of the
steam deck
a new foray into dedicated pc gaming
hardware
the portable device bears more than a
passing resemblance to nintendo's
popular handheld console hybrid the
nintendo switch
given its general size and form factor
but unlike the switch
the steam deck is built to play your
steam library on the go
and the impressive looking piece of tech
is launching this december
the steam deck comes in three different
versions but each of these offers the
same level of performance
you won't need a more expensive version
in order to play games with more
demanding system requirements
where they differ is in their storage
options there's a 64 gigabyte model
priced at 399 dollars usd
one with 256 gigabytes of storage at 529
and a 512 gigabyte model for 6.49
the pricier models also get some
additional perks the top two models get
a steam community bundle
and the most expensive version comes
with an anti-glare etched screen
but the amount of internal storage is
just part of the story
only the 256 gigabyte and 512 gigabyte
models are equipped with
nvme solid-state drives with the larger
of the two also featuring a faster drive
the 64 gigabyte model by contrast is
equipped with
emmc storage which means the cheapest
steam deck
also has storage that'll be much slower
than you expect
while all three models can have their
storage expanded with a microsd
card buying the cheapest model locks you
into this slower storage solution
so it's worth considering one of the
larger models if you're concerned with
load times
and general usability the steam deck
comes pre-loaded with steamos
a modified version of linux that gives
you a straightforward user interface to
browse
and select games from your steam library
if you're a steam customer
you may already have a wide variety of
games that will be available to play on
steam deck
from the very start but valve has also
emphasized that steam deck is
at its core a pc that means that you can
customize your experience
just like you would on any other pc
including by installing your own
operating system and going outside of
steam for games
hypothetically you could for example
install windows and use that interface
to load up the steam client for your
steam games
and other game clients for other pc
games this may be less elegant than the
built-in steam os
but there's no reason that we know of
why it wouldn't work
the subject of what games you can play
on the steam deck is a situation
that is likely to change between now and
launch and
even after launch as it stands there are
a number of big name
games that aren't supported on linux and
that proton
which valve is using to get certain
games running on linux
doesn't offer a solution for these
include apex legends
destiny 2 and rainbow six siege however
it's entirely possible that support for
these games will come eventually
they may even be supported by the time
steam deck is launched
beyond that there's the issue of storage
space some games are
simply too big to fit on the steam deck
at least in its 64 gigabyte incarnation
you can use a micro sd card to expand
the space and store larger games
but if we're talking about what the
machine can literally play out of the
box
games with larger storage space
requirements won't be compatible
depending on your choice of model as
it's obvious from a single glance
the steam deck strongly resembles the
nintendo switch
with a 720p touchscreen in the middle
and what are essentially halves of a
standard gaming controller
flanking it on either side unlike the
switch's joy-cons
these don't detach from the system
itself so if you want to dock the system
and play on an external display
you'll need a compatible controller the
steam deck can connect to
any standard bluetooth controller though
so you should be able to use any regular
xbox
playstation or third party controller on
the back of the steam deck are four
programmable
grip buttons not unlike what you can
find on the xbox
elite controller on the front the full
size analog sticks are equipped
with capacitive touch sensors that let
the machine know when your fingers are
on them
there are also track pads on both sides
of the screen which
in theory should serve as substitutes
for mouse
input and the steam deck itself has a
gyro sensor built in
for motion controls and a built-in
microphone for voice chat
when using the device you can press the
power button to suspend gameplay
and put the system into sleep mode which
you can then quickly resume from
just like the nintendo switch however
that shouldn't be confused with quick
resume
on the xbox series x and s consoles you
are not able to suspend
multiple games at a time and jump
between them steam deck is equipped with
a 40 watt
hour battery which should top out at 7
to 8 hours of use
by valve's estimate however you can
expect that to decrease
significantly depending on what you're
playing and your chosen graphic settings
this may go as low as 2 hours for the
most intense games
according to what valve told ign in
terms of hardware
the steam deck is impressive in a number
of ways particularly
for the price it remains to be seen how
it will handle a variety of games
particularly if you seek to use features
like ray tracing
but it's worth noting that this has been
designed to facilitate
720p gameplay so the steam deck will
likely not provide
the most high fidelity experience
particularly if you're connecting to a
large external display
the steam deck will include an amd apu
zen 2 cpu
and rdna 2 gpu and it will pack
16 gigabytes of lpddr5 ram
it will also be bigger than the nintendo
switch measuring
298 millimeters wide 117 millimeters
tall
and 49 millimeters thick compare that to
the switch
which is 117 millimeters wide without
attached joy-cons
102 millimeters tall and 13.9
millimeters thick
what's more the steam deck is pretty
heavy valve says it'll weigh about 669
grams
which is about a pound and a half that's
around twice
as heavy as the switch it might be time
to start doing some wrist workouts so
you don't get carpal tunnel
the steam deck supports micro sd cards
for memory expansion
which may be especially necessary if you
purchase the base model that comes with
64 gigabytes of internal storage
valve has also promised that a dock is
coming with price to be announced
which will allow you to plug the device
into your tv or monitor
and play on a bigger screen a lot like
the nintendo switch can
each model also comes with its own
carrying case
although only the most expensive model
includes what valve is calling
an exclusive carrying case other pc
accessories like your mouse
keyboard and what have you will also be
compatible with the steam deck
as will bluetooth controllers and
headphones valve has also confirmed that
you'll be able to use a usbc hub
to hook up more accessories to the steam
deck pre-orders for the steam deck are
now available through steam
and through valve's official website for
the device
for the time being pre-orders are simply
reservations
requiring a five dollar deposit that
will be put toward the final purchase
price at a later date
we're not sure how long valve will keep
pre-orders open so if you want a steam
deck
you should try to lock it in soon to
hear our thoughts on the steam deck
with some analysis about who valve's
device is for and whether it'll compete
with the nintendo switch
watch our breakout from this week's
after dark podcast
you can read even more about the steam
deck on gamespot.com right now and stay
tuned for even more coverage in the
future
and as always if you want to see more be
sure to drop a like
and hit that subscribe button
[Music]
you